-Performing "You're Not Here"
from her new album
"Chapter One, Verse One,"
here's Emmy, Grammy and Tony
Award winner Cynthia Erivo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ -I wish you knew
the person I am ♪
♪ The way I hold my heart
in my hands ♪
♪ The way I sing like it's
the air that I breathe ♪
♪ People say it's everything ♪
♪ I whistle still ♪
♪ Crack my knuckles too ♪
♪ 'Cause these are
the two things you ♪
♪ You taught me to do ♪
♪ They get on
my mother's nerves ♪
♪ Maybe 'cause I learned it
from you ♪
♪ I hope one day there's more
for me to choose ♪
♪ Until that day I wish this
to be true ♪
♪ When I run ♪
♪ I'm running to your arms ♪
♪ And when I sing,
I'm singing to your heart ♪
♪ I feel you near ♪
♪ In my moment of fear ♪
♪ But when I open up my eyes ♪
♪ I see it clear ♪
♪ It was only in my dreams
that you are here ♪
♪ You're not here ♪
♪♪
♪ Did you know I dropped
out of school? ♪
♪ Nineteen years old ♪
♪ With a whole lot to prove ♪
♪ Carried on through my doubts ♪
♪ All to figure out
who I was meant to be ♪
♪ Mmm, mmm-mmm ♪
♪ Ten years later,
29 years old ♪
♪ Got my poor heart broken ♪
♪ Did it over the phone ♪
♪ Was in a hotel room ♪
♪ And I was all alone ♪
♪ I was alone ♪
♪ I wanted to run ♪
♪ Run into your arms and cry ♪
♪ As you held me to your heart ♪
♪ Feel you near
in my moment of fear ♪
♪ But when I opened up my eyes
and wiped the tears ♪
♪ It was only in my dreams
that you were here ♪
♪ And now you're missing out on
how I get to live the life ♪
♪ That I forever and a day
had dreamed all about ♪
♪ And it's a shame
you won't be there ♪
♪ For the joy
I've yet to share ♪
♪ Because in spite of you,
I'm here ♪
♪ Oh, yes, I'm here ♪
♪ And I'm in love
and it's for real ♪
♪ And you'll never get
to meet them ♪
♪ But I truly hope you're happy
where you are ♪
♪ It's unfortunate we end
before we start ♪
♪ I hope you know I'll always
love you from afar ♪
♪ But I can't ignore the part ♪
♪ 'Cause you'll never be here ♪
♪♪
♪ Never be here ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]